yesterday for justin fields chris and
we're going to talk about that for a
little bit jets 49ers falcons panthers
broncos patriots patriots reportedly
attended josh mcdaniels was there i saw
it can't hide it even with the mask up
over the nose i can tell that's josh
mcdaniels so he was there
and
i don't know if you saw any of the
throws um i saw one throw that looked a
lot like the throw that had everyone
impressed the last time around yeah
rolling to the left and throwing down
that direction not the zack wilson flick
of the wrist the other way when you're
running full speed to the left but still
impressive by justin fields
your impression on him after now two pro
day workout well i mean again
there's not a lot to dislike about this
guy or a human or the specimen or
anything like that i mean there's not i
mean in these kind of environments too
he's gonna thrive hey he's big he's
strong you know he looks like an adonis
and he's got great feet and of course
can really run gotta ask up kyle yeah
kyle yeah come on kyle what the hell are
you doing and then you know he's got a
million dollar personality too as far as
anybody you talk to a big smile got
charisma all that so i didn't expect to
come away from that workout to go in oh
wow there's issues there i will still
say
i have concerns about the motion the way
he throws the football i do
even in the workout yesterday i saw a
number of the throws a number of them
you know and again mike you've heard me
talk about this a little bit my biggest
issue with it and i don't know if it's
going to be fixable with him and of
course it leads to moments of
you know
moments and games and and long stretches
of just like where you go
wait what the hell was that how how how
did he throw the last tenth row so
awesome and now these five or six throws
are this bad how the hell does that
happen and that's what concerns me about
fields you know that that is and and
again if anybody out there sees the
clips of the throwing or anything like
that the one thing he does always mike
is it's it's the elbow this back elbow
there's a hitch in his giddy up there
and he tries to create fake force with
that which leads to a slower release and
him not just letting it rip out there
that that's to me the biggest complaint
about those type of workouts with justin
fields as compared to trevor lawrence
zack wilson
even trey lance or mac jones you know
they played their workouts like they
were playing in the game like let me get
back fist oh let me throw it really
quick and let me let it rip because i
got all the confidence in the world that
i know where the ball is going to end up
when i watch justin fields i would see a
little bit like all right all right wait
do this do this and okay throw okay it
was complete good and that's my only
negative and i don't mean to be negative
about the guy but that's just my real
assessment of him as a player and
thrower
and
as you were explaining that yeah
i had a little bit of a flashback to
some of the concerns about patrick on
homes and i'm not trying to compare
contrast the two but remember four years
ago right there was just kind of this
weird vague footwork decision making
yeah bad throws concerns and there
really was not going into the 2017 draft
one of the reasons because the chiefs
kept their mouths shut the saints kept
their mouths right shut other teams that
knew what my homes were going to be they
kept their shut right completely shut
right but there was just kind of this
vague sense well yeah he can be pretty
good but there's just some stuff about
his game that yeah
you know
does it really translate and i i felt
some of that as you were describing feel
yeah i i i and you know
part of it really is the quality of
coaching the guys get at the college
level the coaching definitely keeping
them from being as good as they
can be and will be at the next level
there's no doubt there's no doubt
there's some of that and listen i'll sit
there and tell you like yeah i don't
always think ohio state's offense does
him justice he's put some situations and
has some reads on plays where i just
want to go
i i don't understand this i've known
offense and football my whole life i
don't really get what he's reading or
what this offense is trying to deliver
or how it's helping the quarterback
there is a lot of that i think you got
to be true to that like hey fields and
lance to me is two of the more
tougher evaluations ever they because
listen uh yeah you're right with justin
fields you know there there's there's a
superstar element there is there's no
doubt about it with with as powerful as
his arm is and as great a athlete and
body he has and all that you go he could
be
legit unbelievable football player watch
out he'll be a great quarterback but i
also think there's an incredibly like a
low floor a bust factor there too
because of some of the issues we talked
about that's where it's really tough it
really is i i wouldn't be surprised if
it went either way and then like i'll be
the first one to sit here he gets
drafted somewhere and becomes a
superstar i'll go damn i was wrong you
know the things that i thought were
problems they weren't or he fixed them
or whatever uh there is some high-end
talent to certainly like mike it's just
some of that low end stuff that scares
me to death
by the way one of the benefits of never
really cleaning up my area is i still
have sitting here my 2017 nolan naraki
draft preview listen to the patrick
patrick mahomes weaknesses right and
this doesn't come out anymore i don't
know whatever happened to nolan naraki
but weaknesses well maybe it's this
evaluation
well here we go but i mean strength
there's a lot of good in the strength
here are the weaknesses erratic decision
maker with double digit interception
totals the last two seasons operates
heavily in a simplistic shotgun spread
offense that calls for one look reads to
many stationary targets overly reliant
on his extreme arm talent and gets
careless with his mechanics and
unorthodox delivery too often throwing
off his back foot from odd angles and
even attempting left-handed passes on
the move all the stuff
that became amazing the strongest part
of his game
his weaknesses in college have made him
one of the great quarterbacks of all
time so you never know no you never know
it's not a knock on nolan rocky no i
guess you never know how that weakness
may be parlayed into
one of the most fascinating and
compelling things we've seen in years on
a football field well that's like the
context of the situation and some of
that stuff that's where it does become
important at least in my eyes as far as
evaluating the quarterback you know
even with josh allen you'd probably see
some of those type of stuff but also
with the context of like all those
negatives you talked about right mike i
would go well first off double digit
interceptions they throw the ball 65 or
70 times a game
so you're gonna throw double digit
interceptions when you're playing that
type of offense yeah they weren't the
most talented team in the world and like
a guy with mahomes they gave him the
green light because they knew like some
of those games just like josh allen up
in wyoming they were like you're gonna
have to make magic and pull seven
rabbits out of your butt and probably
three shamrocks on top of that for us to
win the game so go ahead there's no
leash on you you know if you throw it
off your back foot and it's a tight
window so what we'll deal with it you
know so you have to take into account
too what they're being coached at times
too to evaluate that type of stuff and
you know i think sometimes that's where
people can miss on guys like mahomes or
allen because of that aspect of what
they're being asked to do it doesn't
necessarily always do them justice as
far as the nfl evaluators and
translating to the nfl because they're a
little wild and crazy but as we saw both
guys reigned it in appropriately
throughout their careers my home's much
faster
and and the reality is
as the game becomes more and more data
driven right you would think at some
point someone would come up with an
equation a formula an algorithm for
spotting the guys that are destined to
become
perennial pro bowlers if not hall of
famers and they all get taken the first
10 or 15 picks in the draft we're still
not there
because fundamentally
the coaching is going to be different
the quality of the teammate is going to
be different maybe better maybe worse
maybe same the quality opposition is
going to be
better
and
the projection
even for the people chris who do this
all the time the projection is virtually
impossible because we don't know how
that guy's going to respond when he
takes a step to the next level and we
know from experience there's a ceiling
over everyone somewhere between what
they did in college in the pro football
hall of fame and the only way to find
out where that ceiling is is to let
these guys
try to stand up and see where they
finally bump their head yeah that that's
right i mean that's that's that's all
you can do as an evaluator as a coach to
you know take the things into account to
what you said okay wait we drafted we
like the player
here's the strengths we see as the
player here you know through training
camp otas we see the strengths we see
the weaknesses of the player okay let's
work on the weaknesses but
you know let's make sure we design plays
and call plays that are more towards his
strengths as we work on these weaknesses
you know that those are things that yeah
it's on the coach to develop that get
those bad habits out do those type of
things and that is the great thing about
justin fields with all the things that i
question about his throwing that i have
concerns about
you know his his great athletic ability
in his body will buy him time to be able
to fix that even if he gets thrown into
the fire right away it will because
they'll be able to get away with moving
the ball with some of his his movement
stuff and doing stuff like that and
there and then that will also lead to
some easier defenses which will not make
him have to maybe throw real complex
route patterns and offensive plays that
way again that makes it easier for him
to work on some of the mechanical issues
and then you hope okay you know after a
year wait now this guy we think he's got
it right fields he's fixed some of these
throwing issues let's start to open up
the playbook and do that and and expand
on the passing game from in the pocket
and all that that's what that's what
you're hoping with with justin fields
and uh you know there's certainly that
possibility there but you know like i
said it just scares me a little bit
and
i don't know whether it's just people
trying to drive interest and build
mystery for that third overall pick and
i'm kind of caught up in it we're two
weeks away nobody really knows what the
49ers are going to do how much of it is
hey we kind of like this we're trolling
a little bit how much of it is they
moved up there and they still don't know
whether it's mac jones or justin fields
or trey lance do you think there's a
reasonable shot that your guy kyle
shanahan who we saw talking to justin
fields yesterday personally attending
that pro day after personally attending
mac jones and will personally attend
trey lance pro day 2.
do you really think they don't know what
they're going to do
no i don't i don't i don't i think they
have a really good idea of what they're
going to do right you know again you
know my thought
you know knowing my friend john lynch
those guys right i would think that like
it's like one of those things where it's
like hey it's they're 90
95 sold on one guy
but they're gonna make sure they see it
all
and feel really comfortable about that
one guy
you know and comparing them to each
other and do all their homework that way
i think you know it's it's a huge pick
it's the number three pick in the draft
and it's a defining pick for kyle
shanahan and the 49ers he made a really
bold move by going up from 12 to three
you know the pressure's on him here you
know people are going to look at this
pick for a long time and go wait who did
he draft and what happened here with
this situation and you're already seeing
like you know people are ready to jump
on the mac jones thing i mean mac jones
doesn't work whoa shanahan's gonna take
a lot of crap there's no doubt about
that you know so that's gonna be a bold
move it decides to go that direction you
know the public safe pick
is definitely fields or lance
you know the normal fan the casual fan
seems to certainly be able to get their
their uh their head around that
way greater than mac jones and sometimes
i think it's just because of the the way
the guys look topically you know that
that affects that
you know while listening intently to you
i have been trying desperately to find
your 2003 scouting report so i could
read off your weekly oh i wish you i
wish did you find it i can't find them
you you have managed to scrub google
well of any and all weaknesses of chris
sims coming out in the time i found a
few random articles right but uh yeah
nothing nothing uh nothing that uh that
would that would let me read off all the
things that the scouts were worried
about right do you remember and were you
motivated by that stuff uh i mean to a
degree you know
listen i knew the areas i needed to work
on my in my game or anything like that
the one thing that i think you know i
was motivated by or the the stigma
around me was i couldn't win the big
game you know i couldn't win the big
game we couldn't beat oklahoma you know
when we were one and they were two and
we were three and they were two i lost
those games and then i had the
interceptions in the first half of the
big 12 championship game against
colorado that i was the reason we lost
that game so you know i got that label
on like can't perform in the clutch and
do that that yeah it pissed me off
because i was like the opposite guy of
that my whole life growing up but now i
was considered the guy that was wilting
under pressure so that bothered me it
really did i certainly heard that and i
was very eager to kind of prove that
wrong once i got to the nfl
i have found an article
from espn.com
january 13 2003 sims tries to rewrite
his scouting report it's easy to find
it's easy to find on google
do you remember this article and do you
remember who wrote the article not at
all no i mean i'm going to say that that
like
that's got to be right before my senior
bowl something like that there that year
yeah and it was talking about how a
scout tells a story of going to
university of texas to study tape on
you and others and the scout sees
nothing's changed same simple scheme
same vertical route same fallout for
chris sims cursed with the fallout is a
big game failure and it's a positive
article it's popping you up
written by
adrian wojnarowski wow
wow isn't that wild that is wild but
you know
hey that's part of evaluating a
quarterback that that is you know again
yeah the scheme itself things like that
you know yeah i i knew
at my senior year in college that like
our offense wasn't real expansive and
that we were pretty simple i mean my
junior year i walked off the field with
bob stoops after we lost to oklahoma and
he told me to keep my head up and that
your offense isn't very good and we know
everything about your offense you know
he basically like tried to like cheer me
up that way
but hey that's part of evaluating and
doing that stuff but like in all
seriousness i got to tampa bay
and though one of the first like
sessions gruden had with me with putting
in plays we had this play it was called
two jet bullseye and i went oh he he
kept hearing me like him and ha
and he's going what what about what what
about this play and i was like man i was
like if we had this play
we would have won the national
championship i probably won the heisman
we had no answer for tampa 2. that was
our issue oklahoma played tampa 2
against us and we couldn't beat it
and that led to you know me looking like
an idiot out in the field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports